yeah welcome to this video playing
against an international master Michael
pogroms key yeah Russia release got lots
of title players yeah someone asked me
why do you never play Queens the to go
up I don't know I mostly forgot about it
it's no particular reason not to play it
so I played d6 there's also be 6 all
kinds of lines are possible here mmm so
what is the setup with Knight f3 d2 or
d3 now let's go nada three wondering
about g5 but probably this is nonsense
okay putting the night here to to
control you form and I want to try to
play you fall in one move with pass or
if I Ebola and I'm very I'm not very
well developed I hope this doesn't all
94 wow wow I can just play 94
94 Bishop d8 Knight c3 Bishop e7 maybe
maybe I can still play it but I really
have got about this possibility right if
this is still ok for me I'm lucky I'm
just lucky yeah well how does he even
keep the night b3 isn't the night trap
now I can take on default course the
ayah you can take on d4 but if I take on
c5 where does the night go at the end of
all this interesting threatening rook
see one now trapping the night dad was
still it's still bad by me I simply
overlooked 294 I am it's it's very very
normal motif in these positions you are
you always must considered so why am I
not winning a piece tell me Rossi one
night a to look c2 and kearns black
forfeit duty disconnection yeah we know
that the Pullman's way of resigning yeah
I understand that he's frustrated I
really it's it's obvious that I didn't
intend this probably hey I forgot about
the move but maybe it doesn't work it's
not working I just I just fired up the
computer it's it's not working in this
case I was also thinking that this is a
theoretical position it it looks very
very normal see txt fourths of course
the the the simple option that is
certainly alright for black but this
doesn't seem too too
simply yeah yeah the computer is on plus
two showing that i'm basically winning a
piece for two pawns yeah just luck just
lucky so nothing that I planned yeah
quick opening win thanks for watching